the gun turns out later it was plastic
races down the aisle towards the cockpit
I stick my leg out
he's down I'm on top then five other
passengers jump on him too I'm a hero
I'm on chat shows I tell my story well I
hint at broader issues
I've got views about security the
economy the environment the PM invites
me to lunch people are listening to me
it's a pivotal moment every one time I
meet Mark Zuckerberg we get talking he's
got this idea he's wondering if it could
work I encourage him
frenetic times we cut a deal I'm sitting
on a good chunk of Facebook shares I get
up an hour earlier in the mornings sit
in my dressing gown at the kitchen table
with a mug of tea I used to want to
write a novel now I'm actually doing it
all my observations of people over the
years are going into it this is what I
really think and feel the atmosphere at
dawn the sadness of childhood I'm
writing hard my agent really loves the
manuscript Dave Eggers has written a
brilliant blur I've just heard it's on
the book a long list the guys at work
are not going to believe it I'm
introduced to Keira Knightley she looks
me in the eye we smile there's a
connection she's lonely I understand her
one day she drops by the office I'm very
modest about it she tells me what she
really feels that she hates being famous
that she cries sometimes I hold her hand
give her a hug
I'm her best friend and her lover I have
magic powers I can go back in time a v16
but know everything I know now I keep my
brain but swap my body I sail through
exams yeah it's a little boring maybe
but it's so satisfying hitting every
single grade I go to a different
University I know exactly what to say
and do at all times seduction
works so well I have youth and
experience no one says no to me not even
Alice I've just read in the news that
guy from college who was always ahead of
me
who got a huge job in banking is really
sickly it's horrible but a relief I look
almost like I do now
but without anyone noticing gradually
line by line the wrinkles and the
blemishes fade my mouth becomes a touch
more symmetrical lips and a little more
pretty my ears get just a little smaller
and ears themselves over a few weeks
more neatly into the side of my head
people smile at me more often in the
street my colleagues listen I'm still me
just the way I was supposed to be we
keep quiet about the fantasies we have
because we're not sure how other people
will react but they're doing the same
thing we should go easy on ourselves a
fantasy is sometimes just the best shape
a wish
can take we don't always have a plan and
it may just be the best we can do but
fantasies also mean freedom from
responsibility we're free to make it
perfect and not have to worry about what
it would actually be like
in reality